what about thinner
well no thinner was thinner was a great
experience and a terrible experience I
had a wonderful actor there Robert Sean
Burke and then I and I did I did I did I
did rehearse that and I thought
everybody was just terrific
and
that was a very difficult piece it's a
character piece
I enjoyed it I enjoyed thinner it wasn't
too disturbing for you no I liked it it
was it was it was dark it was weird it
was I remember seeing it in the theater
um but when you have trouble with an
actor do you ever Raise Your Voice do
you ever get mad do you ever lose your
[ __ ] have you ever lost your [ __ ] Tom
Holland
yeah a number of times but I never lost
it I don't don't think I ever lost it
with actors have you ever said God damn
it I told you to do that move to yeah
well what happens is you as as the movie
proceeds as you get closer and closer to
the end the pressure from the studio
Builds on you to finish it to cut the uh
to save money I don't think I've ever
been involved in a movie where they
weren't knocking on the door in the last
two or three weeks saying can we cut
this can we cut that and it's just
horrible it's always stressful you got
that guy on set who's like we gotta go
we gotta go you're gonna miss it we
can't do that we gotta cut this and
you're always you're always ending up a
magic hour with three shots left that
you need and time for only one always
that's all that's always